Hello! Friends! Is everyone good ? oh I'm sorry about
c-sharp I'll tell later why okay
well I hope right like it's it's good to
have this kind of conference right to meet
people and actually today I'm gonna show you
something that I I was not expert I was actually
researching and actually I found some bug and
then node.js score and it was like no no it's
not a bug it's me doing something wrong so I'm
gonna go through this whole process okay so uh
first of all all of this presentations are
already online so you should follow me on
Twitter I'm gonna publish there and you can chat
later as well if you can please take pictures
mention the event mention myself this helps
us a lot with the work with bingoing all right
so first of all I was just like you attending
some events I actually uh you know write Brazil
don't speak English much as well so I was there
struggling a lot to learn English but I was with
a lot of people on the open source and helping on
the node.js core and some collaborators and there
were some activities there to help you to get your
first commit there so collaborators were just
giving you some tasks easy test I'm gonna show you
the first one but you know right there are a lot
of environment things and other kind of stuff
that you you might do a part of the the whole
thing so on this Workshop you know I'm not a good
photographer right but this image means a lot for
me well this was actually what the taxi the task
I got it was just to switch the test right you can
see it was very simple but for me it meant a lot
because I should follow the node.js style guide
I actually should a make the environment work and
a lot of other stuff well after struggling a lot
with this code I finally got this email and was
like your name is now on the node.js card I was
like oh my God I'm gonna show it to my mom now
so this was really nice and for everyone who
finished it they gave a a pin so this ping
for me was like oh my God this is so nice
well this was like 2018 and I was since then
trying to find something nice to work on the
node.js car but I just gave up because there
were not much information on the internet for
me I was really struggling a lot well but
I'm talk to you now about the book I found
I think you're gonna relate that you know when you
are sure that you are making something like you've
done like 10 times and you're like no I don't need
Google I don't know how to do this and actually it
wasn't working like I had no idea what's working
and actually it was a bug it finally was a bug
and I was able to try finding it well let me
introduce you first what was the idea and then
I walked through that problem well first of all
the problem was using the child process first
of all how many of you are back-end Developers
all right you from 10 developers who use Jest
npm why were all affected by the same bug but
I'm gonna go through later well in the node.js
score you can use charity processes to spin up
other processes you can actually uh run parallel
tasks and communicate with other programs basic uh
this is the goal to make this work you should have
two files the first one is the child right the
the test that is going to execute in background
so here I'm just listening for a message and I'm
just sending a message right away make sure that
you remember the logs on the child I have message
received on child and here in the parents there
are a lot of code right but I'm just focused on
this part all this code is ECMAScript so the whole
book is on ECMAScript not required uh not CommonJs
but here I'm just spinning up this file this
program and listen to the message and I'm just
sending the message to the child so the child is
receiving a message and the parent is sending and
receiving at the same time all right so when I try
to run this code I was preparing the classes and
see I'm just receiving the message on the parent
the child didn't receive anything I was like oh
my God no no it's not possible what's going on
here I've done this code a lot but then I was
like what if I do some like workaround I put
a settimeout there and I was waiting and then
I received the message so I figured maybe the
the child process is not ready yet to receive this
message so maybe this is a book but I was like no
no maybe it's just me doing some mistake as always
right Friday code after 6 p.m it's hard to think
well the way I thought how it was a burden how
this bug actually affected all of you here when
I started researching I found a lot of issues open
on Jest  and a lot of other packages and
people from like maintainers saying no no this
is not our fault it's node.js they should fix
it on the node.js side it almost like oh my God no
one had fixed this yet so maybe I should like try
fixing it but I had no idea so the whole point
of this talk is about commuting right it's not
about being specialist and not nothing like I've
I've helped I've had helped a lot of from these two
people. Anna is like one of the best persons ever she
actually uh wrote a lot of popular modules on the
node.js core like worker threads C++  I would say right and Rich is one of people
of the node.js technical steering committee
who helps like choosing what is going on to the
node.js with the I would say the bureaucratic
part right so this it's hard so I start talking
to each other about my ideas and actually
my idea was kind of introducing a new event
so when the sharing process is ready to receive
a message I would send it right away I was like
well it makes sense using my mind however I was
talking to Anna and she said I have another idea
maybe you should just in queue the message until
you have some child available right I was like oh
this would make more sense let me go through this
now the problem was I have the main process and I
have between the process you have some ChannelHub right
some messages going back and forth I
was trying to send a message but the child process
wasn't ready yet so Anna's idea was I would create
like an in-memory database some object there that
is gonna store all those messages and when we had
the child ready then this communication Hub
will get all the message clean the messages
and send to the child processes and then when I
try to send If the child process is ready it was
okay I was like oh this is so much better than
I thought but it's good to know right so first
of all I was like okay I want some feedback and
I  actually wanna I wanna help implement this
right so I wrote the whole issue there but notice
only the first line said I would
like to help fix this bug you know there are
a lot of contributors there that might fix this
bug in like two minutes 30 minutes right but I
really want I really like to go through and to
learn more how I could do this so the community
helped a lot and a lot of people said yeah this
is a bird go go forward and try fixing this
bug well the first thing was to compile node.js
like have you ever tried to compile on Node.js
it's like my machine back then wasn't that good
so it took like two hours to compile and every
time I was changing some code it must be compiled
again I was like no no no I'm doing something
wrong here this shouldn't be that hard so reading
the docs right we should do this read more often
I found some some ideas to actually read our JS
code from our uh path right from our directory so
I waited for the whole hour I'll go through some
lunch and then it compiled after this compilation
I actually got to the file like the child process
I wrote some code there and I actually executed
the node.js that the compilation process just
made it I was like oh it's working then I changed
again I was like oh very nice and now I'm I can't
remember right oh very nice now I'm able to to
try working now I can print it out I can debug
it and I can test what's going on right it's not
that difficult anymore well so I start coding a
lot trying to get some answers I try like reaching
Anna a lot I think I annoyed her a lot too but she
she didn't complain so it was nice well the first
thing I got to the node.js process uh file and I
was like looking for the 2 000 lines of
code and then I found these two messages two two
functions right we have handle message and emit
so they go us if there's no listening which is
wait and save a list and then we keep sending so I
said right, here's the place I'm gonna start
notice that I didn't write any code any test yet right
I just I was just trying to prove my concept back
then and then I would start creating the test but
look I created the list very straightforward I was
actually trying to listen how many listeners I had
waiting for messages if there is no listeners
there or if it's like an internal message I just
figure that node.js talks to himself for some way
And then if there
is no one asking for maters I would just add
to this function and make it work anyway well look
at the difference right before one line after this
whole uh new logic code well the next step is
actually when I have someone trying to listen
right when I have a new listener I will actually
get those messages see if there is any painting
message and then I'll call that admit function
and then I will clear the all the message notice
that there are a lot of ugly code here like for
many people but this was just the first version
right then I'm gonna refactor and do this better
but back then I was like I want to make this work
my idea must work my proof of concept
proof of concept should work here
all right well after this I came back to our our preview example so now Ihave exactly the same file that I had there and
then I tried working this and then I got this
message I was like oh my God and now it worked
now it worked now I can go through try fixing uh
submitting the pr finally I do I did something
that he affected a lot of people right so this is
uh really nice so then I write the test so here
the test I'm doing everything in a single file
it's a single-file application here I just get
uh by the arguments so if there's no argument I
know that I will call the pirate right so I'm just
a spin up a process send me a message and actually
I'm waiting for this message once I have it I will
just compare If the message I sent was the same I
received not that hard back then and then here
on the else, I will just wait for the message and
send it back all right the problem was the child
wasn't receiving in time look that there's no setTimeout
anymore right oh very nice all right so I
ran all of the node.js that suite and I break the
node.js everything stopped working was like
oh my God no please what I'm gonna do now I break
all their tests right what was working the node.js
but you know when we're working in any kind of
application we feel like oh we it's too complex
but most of the problems we have we fix with if
right I was just checking if the property was
there if it was just keep going then I ran my
test again my actually my my proof of concepts
I ran the test that was failing and the whole test
suite again and then 100% okay so I got through on
the docs and I was like what is the next step
but the code is working so let's cheer up let's
have some beer right now some amazing well I came
back and I had to run some linking right to check
if my style guide was following uh what node.js
cares and I mean it wasn't that good right 45 errors
for people who was behind so I had to fix
one by one so I should have like configured my
vscode but that's fine it worked and finally I
opened the request following the docs it's very
straightforward you write a title you
have a description and actually, you link all
the references you had to make this PR all right
now what's the worst part right you submit and you
you have the syndrome right like oh my God I'm
not good enough my code is horrible but
it's still the testing was passing so I was like
oh man I mean they won't close my PR because it's
working right it's ugly but it's working well I
got a lot of feedback and I think this is the main
point of working for free on the open source you
learn a lot of stuff that you might like not have
seen in working with APIs or create applications
right in this case, I was creating a public field
and I do just said well you could use symbols
to create private Fields I was like oh yeah a
lot of symbols are right but yeah it was really
nice uh actually he was saying that I shouldn't
rely on the array iterator a iterator is a global
object that someone can mutate and break the whole
node.js so I couldn't use the spread operator
the three dots right there and I had to use
reflect apply which is like like utilitary from
utils on the node.js to make the same thing
well and for me the most interesting one was Jasnellsaying
well this is a performance issue
you're gonna make the node.js very slow because
of this I didn't really know I just changed the
for loop from outside the nextTick to inside the
nextTick I was like very nice then I was this is
kind of I think uh Eleanor said on his talk in her
talk like we feel like when people are questioning
like they are the whole like the owner of
the truth right but sometimes they're not right
sometimes they're just asking you uh Anna just
said okay James now said okay but now we have
another problem you have the race condition it
could happen that you're trying to read a message
that is not even on the node.js yet and you have
like undefined it's not a fan oh yeah the classic
and the finals the adventure all right and then
I got this message again you are now on on a
a version of the node.js and I was like this is so
amazing my PR got to node 17 and I saw my name
I would say I was about to print it and put up
a board like a huge board on my wall because it was
so amazing yeah I really like it this is really
really nice but you know right when we are working
with programming in general, you know that's not
that easy right sometimes and suddenly the pr was
closed and someone just made this question oh well
you fixed on 17 but the current version is 14 will
this be fixed and 14. I was like oh my God yeah I
should try doing and I do that said oh you we are
community you should go there try to backport
basic copy paste the code to run on the branch
on the 14 version I was like no way I'm gonna do
this right I did there and I'm gonna do it again
so here I did the same idea I did the backport
there copy paste and now I thought this was way
better because when it was approved on a backport
you have like less contributions like it feels
like I'm doing something that is not much people
doing right so it was there again it was really a
feeling of accomplishment right because you know
millions of people Google Microsoft every big
company has something working with node.js React
or everything and now your name has been written
there even though it wasn't something that hard
right when when you look through this solution
you said no this is anyone could do this but to
go through the whole process and to figure out
the solution this is something that we developers
we face every day right so working on working on
open source or for companies that is not that
different the difference is actually uh task
management right this is the hardest part well all
of this talk is about node.js and community I'm
not here to say no I'm good I just fixed somethingnode.js
no everyone could do this right but when
we try to face a new challenge and when we figure
that people have the same struggle that we have
this is something that changes everything right
uh we were talking right I flew from Brazil 30
hours from there and now I feel home like I see
people that has the same struggles I have and
this is really amazing for everything and actually
for me like for all places I've been it's exactly
like a family right so this is really really nice
well because of these things trying to help a lot
I finally got a nomination on the node.js so I
was actually contributing without anything there
like any one of you could do there but now I could
like review requests, I could like attend meetings
trying to join some working groups like I joined
now the working group of the node.js tooling
group to work on cli and a lot of stuff there
and you are getting even more deeper right and
learning a lot of for a lot of people and this is
funny because the people that usually you idolize
right they have actually the same questions like
what is not working here it's like I have no idea
let's try fixing it and let's try searching
together so we can find everything okay well
I've been doing a lot of content about node.js on
my channel as well so actually math science right
so I implemented the web socket from scratch
and I learned a lot of stuff so as I'm saying
when you challenge yourself when something
totally out of your comfort zone this helps
a lot to get other contacts and even to make
more money right this is why we're here right
to switch jobs or to make even more money on our
jobs well I actually built a whole textbook it's
like a step by step how I solve the problem so if
you are curious you can actually get the node.js
branch for there and do every step I did until you
reach the same result I did I think this is a good
experiment for you who's curious or if you have
any other idea of how you could implement it right
nice well I'm actually I'm a full-time content
producer so I'm releasing uh training cards right
now about node.js Stream So the most powerful
uh tool there so I'm gonna leave a link at the
end if you are gonna prior register and all the content I've been doing it's
already on my website so everything is there if
you wanna take a look later study more right try
to find more topics to research about you can go
further there and get uh these things all right
well before I finish this talk I will leave
some five seconds for you to take a picture
to get these lights because you know right this
takes a long time to build it and why you take
pictures well I have five minutes so let's take
a selfie right oh let's make some noise well on
three we make some noise all right and we jump
the arms through to there okay so one two three
oh I really enjoyed this alright
thank you so much for having me